Oh man, come on. I I wasn't trying to
pick on you. You look good. I still
believe it looks good.
I'll wear one tomorrow.
I We'll wear today.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
I have a
we have arrived at a junction and our
reading here in
yesterday we discussed the importance of
making as early as possible meaning as
soon soon as it comes in as soon as
it's most immediately feasible.
And we also discuss the dangers
of
failing to make in its time that this is
it is incredibly dangerous and
considered to be a major sin. It is
agreed upon as a major sin for a person
to delay a prayer until its time is out
without a valid excuse.
So we've discussed the importance of
making
specifically
at the earliest time and the dangers of
delaying it and the sinfulness of a
person who misses any prayer but
especially
but there's a middle ground there isn't
there's a middle place between making it
at the very beginning
or missing it entirely.
There's a middle place there and that is
neglecting it
until
you almost miss it, but technically you
didn't miss it.
So putting it off as long as possible
until just a few minutes before its time
is over, a person makes it not because
there was any real reason to do that,
just out of laziness and a lack of
enthusiasm
to pray. And especially this goes for
any prayer but especially
and that middle ground that technical
place where technically they didn't miss
it but the spirits of the prayer they
definitely did miss it. This is what
Allah Subhanahu Waaala is referring to
when he says.
Now we have a narration
regarding this exact phenomenon.
So
this narration is regarding the
sinfulness of a person who delays
until just before sunset.
[Silence]
Malik narrates
that he heard the messenger of Allah.
say, "Behold
the prayer of the hypocrite."
Behold the prayer of the hypocrite. In
one narration, in one wording of this
narration, he repeated this twice
three times.
He says, "Behold the prayer of the
hypocrite.
He will sit and monitor the sun
until the sun is just between the two
horns of a shaitan.
And then he will stand and peck the
ground four times not remembering Allah
in those pecs but very little. This
narration is in Muslim. So here we have
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
capturing
the
prayer of the hypocrite. The hypocrites
they are
many different types. There are those
who are
so hypocritical that they are no longer
Muslim. There are those who are people
who have elements of hypocrisy,
right? And between those two between
those two are many many many areas.
But hypocrisy is not an illness, a
disease that the Muslim ummah will ever
be free of ever.
Someone will always suffer from the from
the ills of hypocrisy.
We look at narrations
that I think most of us know such as the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's statement
the indicator or the sign or the
hallmark of the hypocrite are three
things and in other wording he says four
things. If he promises he breaks his
promise. If he speaks he lies. And if he
gives his word, he breaks his word. We
know this narration, correct? Very
well-known narration of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. And that is that
hypocrisy is a weed that grows in
the heart. Every every Muslim, everyone,
even the companions,
this weed will attempt to grow in your
heart. And you have to do what? Any any
gardeners here amongst us today this
morning? If you are planting, gardening,
what's the what's the thing that if you
fail to do it, your crops will die no
matter how much you water them?
Failing to weed out the invasive species
of weeds that are growing with them. If
you don't weed your garden, it will
choke out your crops. That's how it
works. Hypocrisy is no different.
Hypocrisy is the weed that grows in the
garden of the believer's heart. The
companions
were extremely vigilant of this. And so
they work day and night diligently to
always weed their gardens. Always.
Always.
And what do we mean by weeding the
garden?
Most importantly to always
analyze, judge yourself and continue
to scrutinize yourself and to
seek forgiveness as immediately as
possible in committing any sin because
everyone commits sins. But the
difference between the hypocrite and the
believer is the hypocrite allows those
weeds to grow.
This is what happened to the people who
were given the book before us. Right? In
Allah says,
[Silence]
Is the time not arrived for the
believers to be serious about the
remembrance of Allah and that their
hearts truly become soft and focused on
the remembrance of Allah? And has the
time not arrived that they not be like
those who were given the book before
them? And much time went by and their
hearts became hard. That's what
happened. So when a person first
receives Islam, it's exciting. It's
exhilarating. You want to do everything
perfect. You want to learn. Your your
your heart is open.
But as time goes on, the novelty wears
off. You stop weeding the garden. You
get a little bit less excited, a little
bit less excited. And as time goes on,
if you stop studying, if you stop
learning, if you stop forcing yourself
and training yourself, what's going to
happen? Those good deeds that you used
to do are going to become much more
difficult to do. And there it's going to
become more and more steep of an uphill
battle. That's where hypocrisy comes
from. The weeds are growing in the
garden. You haven't weeded it for a long
time. And so when a person is suffering
from hypocrisy,
what are the indicators?
Well, the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
has dozens of narrations on this subject
alone.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in the
Quran has hundreds of verses speaking
about the hallmarks and the ailments of
hypocrisy. And one of those hallmarks is
that when they get up and go to pray,
they get up begrudgingly, lazily to
pray.
Right? That is the hallmark of the
hypocrite. And so in this narration, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam gives us
the hallmark of the hypocrite in his
prayer. Listen to the narration. He says
this. Behold the prayer of the
hypocrite.
Behold the prayer of the hypocrite.
He will sit idally
monitoring the sun. speaking about
monitoring the sun.
So he is sitting idally. He could pray
at any moment
but he doesn't have to pray at this
moment technically
right.
So he watches the sun until it arrives
between the horns of a shan. This means
that it is just above the horizon
getting ready to set. Then he will
quickly scramble and peck four pecks.
a rooster, a chicken eating
off the ground, pecking.
This is a description, an analogy of his
prayer. It's just
very, very soulless, spiritless.
If it were, if it were an item, it
wouldn't even be sold by Walmart,
right?
worthless. Nobody wants that.
The most begrudging prayer. Well, if I
have to, if I go to hell, I if if I
don't do this, so I guess I'll do it.
This is the spirit of hypocrisy.
If anyone feels that this description in
any way
is befitting,
then this is a good thing. Why is this a
good thing? Because you can change this
immediately. How do you change it? Start
weeding your garden.
Get to work. And just any garden,
when you let the weeds grow all over the
place and you neglect it for weeks or
months or years,
you're going to have a hard first couple
of weeks weeding that garden out and
getting it back to working order.
But then eventually things will smooth
out. So he says that he will peck four
pecs not remembering Allah but very
little during these prayers and for this
reason the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
prohibited a number of things in prayer.
He says
that a person peck in his sujud and
coming up from sujud very quick very
that this be how a crow pecks at
the ground. This is improper form in
sujud which we'll get to all of these
inshallah
subhanahu waala.
[Silence]
Wasam.